uh
ブースと申します
ゾウ14歳のおめりか人です
先ほど素敵なエピ人で10%向いて私も水
を撮りたくなっちゃったんですけど
踊りは非常に下手ですからしませんご安心
してください
代わりには位の話をしましょう
私がするね前からは員の仕事をやり続けて
いる最初はニューヨークでワインの販売
その家さんの仕事をしてて
その後はキャラポニーに飛行して
彼の4にはではワインづくりーの仕事始め
た
でワイン作りは他の4にゃふ
を主アリアミューズいうえんどぅ
フランスで最後は日本日本では20数年前
から前に作っております
でこの数十年のワインず芸人生を過ごして
きて
ワインについていろんなことを思うように
なりました
一つはワインというものは
幅広くいろんな分野に接触している
パッと考えるとワインてー
美味しいお酒ですね
だと思ってるんですけど皆さんもそう思っ
てもらっていいと思いますが
それよりもうちょっと深く考えると
やっぱり西洋の
食文化の
存在感のあるもの近いうちには日本の食
文化にもなると嬉しいことです
だけどそれよりたくさんのところに関係し
ている分野に関係している
例えば
サイン数
医学栄養学
微生物学など実は歴史芸術技術
もちろん農業にも関係していること
で私はどっちかというちょっと
adhd ぽいタイプですから a 8
ワインを通じて色んなことを経験できるの
は非常に魅力でそれで私がお会いに虜に
なりました正しい今日はそこら辺の話を
しようと思ってました全く違うと黒普段
ワインと関係は全くしてないところを話し
ていこうと思ってる自分のワインの経験を
振り返ってみると意外と不思議でえっと
その特徴はもっと彼できているものですよ
ねそれはワインをのもう一つの面は
てワインは
社会を動かす力がある
8このことは初めて経験したのワイン業界
に入ってしすぐ寝よう区でワインの販売を
していった心
ニューヨークは当時も今でも世界のワイン
市場のトップの一つである世界中の生産者
は自分の場合はぬよくて売りたい
で自分 the すくめてた酒屋さんのた
のはそれでは in あふれるほどでした
ほぼ全てのワイン原産国のワインは方並び
しましたた波
ただ私は今ほどといったのは実は一つの国
の場合は棚に置いてなかったわざと
それは南アフリカの y
南は負荷は当時1970年代ですけど
えっとその人種差別的なパータイズ制度
の失効していった国でした
我々そのスタッフは
8その
基本的に
南服のワインを販売すればパー耐えるを
サポートしていると同じように
をもの同じようになると思ったんですから
まずは意味な見やすくの場合は扱うことを
やめて
その次に
代わりにその真南弥助の置いておくはずの
たぬに小さな際置いておきましたこの際ん
でした
もちろんニューヨークの
酒井さんでしたから英語のサインでしたが
日本にアップにすればこのようなもの
つまり
アパ遺体に反対ですので南は服の愛を扱う
ことはしません
この店をこの際お店に置いたら
お客さんが見るかどうか気がつくかどうか
分からなかったんですけど反応が強くすぐ
出たんですよね
必ずしいい反応だっと残念ながら言えませ
ん
あるお客さんとの会話今でも思い出せるん
だけどあの人が自分がその際選んで自分が
8今日1本買って持って帰って妻との思う
と脳もうと思ったんですけどなぜ私がこの
国際的な陰謀にかダム視聴あるかと怒り
ましただが大部分のお客さんの反応が
良かった
皆さんさえを読んで
自分の毎日のコードによるとクハネれて
いる人にも悪影響が出ると気づいてそれで
会話のもとになりますと客さんとそのあ
パールたいる人権などにいろんな話ができ
た非常に良かった
最後には当然
南や服のパー隊制度崩壊された
で南は負荷に住んでいる皆さんが
その基本的な人権を法的にもらうことに
ありましたが
私たちがぬよってやったことはそれと全く
関係ないもちろん影響はゼロだともその
通りに皆目指す家だけど少なくても私たち
のは in love の組いるという
ニューヨークのコミュニティではやった
ことは日々日々たと私は信じます
その次の
社会的の意味のある
ワイの仕事で出来ていれば金時間経って
から
ニューヨークの後私は単4に行こしてそれ
でワイン作りの業界に入りましたワイン
上足んサウ10th に最後になりました
で上策んサテンとしていろんなは入りと
働いて
各は縫いの
製品の品質をレベルアップするために
いろんな疑似やの
あの技術指導させてもらいました
そのきっかけである日
日本のはニューからの問い合わせ電話入り
ました
で自分のテレ東罹患4にから日本は
あんまりにも離れてから最初
断ろうとしたんですけど
その日本のはにの対象は
かなり粘り強いやつでなんか6では変わっ
てきたん
で電話の内容はだいたいあの人が自分の1
に2を説明した
その話聞いてねだんだんなんだ
中から興味湧いてきました
そのワイナリーは
トーチ技研の足利市にある小さな前でココ
ファームワイナリーというところでココ
ファンはいろんな面白いことをやってます
けど一番面白いことが
その後は乾はもっともっと作っておりいう
はその割に基づくドリューは知的障害の
方たちの職場としてできた
お会い緩いと畑
意外と面白い話だとこの全て初めてのは
この方です園長先生河田昇様
で園長先生が
障害の皆さんのうリハビリとして
農作業に名を付けたやはり
その版リカプの人と一緒に外の労働のて
仕事をやれば
全体的に元気な体できるんじゃないかと
園長先生が持ってて
試みが君という小さいの施設を先に作り
ましたでその心もやペンの皆さんが一緒に
暮らして農作業やてたそののウサギの中に
一つの農産物はブドウでした
西承継を食べる部のですけど
でもやはりあのその農業あのブドウ栽培
やってた人たちはプロじゃなくてだいたい
福祉関係の先生などという人たちで
ぶどう作れなくがかなり
なんていう
出来の悪いものが出ました
そのワイナリー仙女語を使うとクズブドウ
ということですけど房の形が変なものとか
虫食いの入っているブドウとかそういう
ものも出たんでそれは売り物にならないん
で普段来まってるんですけど園長先生がお
酒好きなものですから
そのものと言っておいて実家してワイン
つまり蜜ぞ
内緒ですけどもういなくなった勝った
大丈夫ですけど
でもそれもやはりえっえっとで園長先生が
8それを数年連続であったら
a の的にワイン醸造と販売ショート決定
して y に立ち上げた
でもそれもやはりあのう友達同士で飲む
自家製ワインとお金で売る
ワインの製品のレベルが違うから最初は
うまく出来ず私を選んでもらいました
で自分の素の職業
ワインづくりと全く関係ないと思った
福祉関係の仕事のその組み合わせが非常に
も白いから私はうん最終的にはじゃあ
ちょっと日本にちょっと顔出していこうと
思った
20数年前でしたら
で最初にの日本に来て正
+ by ねそう感じたんですよね
えっと個人的にはココファン袋目で務めた
ことはすごく良かったなぜかというと私は
その知的障害の皆さんとすごい仲良かった
区
歳あの当時は気がついてなかった多分皆
さんの命から見ると私は同じイレブンだっ
たんですよねやっぱり外国人が日本に来る
と
最初は言葉できないし
自分の感じていることは伝えられないし
えっとその周りのコードは理解できない
からまるで版利確の人でした
中はどしてあの迎えてくれたがすごい
良かった仕事の面はどっちかというと
そんなには納得しなかったやはりあの日本
のワインづくりの条件ブドウの品種
紀子どうじょ
あとはその y の商品の文化は自分の女
らかの4に押していやヨーロッパのしてた
もの止まった違って最初はあまり役に立て
なかったと自分がそう思ったんですが
その一生懸命栽培醸造やってる皆さんの
頑張っている姿を見たら私ももうちょっと
頑張れば動力すれば
ちょっと役に立つことができると思って
もうちょっといていこうと思うもう20年
に十数年早回りすると今20数年のココ
ファーム試みができていることを
振り返ってみると出来事はある程度は納得
してるなかなかいい仕事をしていると思い
ます当時は3万本の生産量で今現在は
30万本まで増やしている
その上には結構評判の
いいお酒もできているえっと2000年の
大きなは冷めた
でココファン動画に使ってもらってそれは
初めて日本の国産は日本の公式晩餐会に
使われてた
その後
えっと2006年の北海道洞爺くさめてみ
も
江東シールを貼る
g 7の関係の収めて披露しまで黒浜んの
ワインを使ってもらった
今でも今日も黒ファンこころ皆さんが容易
ブドウ良いワインづくりのために頑張り
続けています
で国ファンドいろんな優秀なスタッフが
入りまして私にはの仕事には割と余裕が
できた状態になっちゃって
次のチャレンジをしようと思っその次の
チャレンジすを期限がココファンで務めた
時の感じたこと先ほど言いましたが
生産量はこの頃ココファンでは3万から
30万本増えてその追加分の葡萄の原料
の買い付けのために私は長い間日本列島を
回って行っていろんな地方でいろんな農家
さんと出会っていろんな話も出来てて
で感じたのは日本の農業は非常に弱い状態
ますます農業の面積が減ってます
ますます農作業に関わってる人数が減少し
てます
先進国のなか
一番自給率食料の自給率の低いのは我々の
陰に方
このままにしていくと now 一方的に
日本の農業
悪くなるという心配で私がじゃあ過ぎの
仕事をするなら
小さい範囲でも
日本の農業にちょっと元気をつけたいと
思って
2009年
8妻と娘と他色の移住してその後には
小さなワイナリーを始めた東 ry 練り
というところ
東 rin はごく普通の場合に特に黒
ファンで比べるとすごく積まれないぐらい
に普通のはニューですけど一つだけの特徴
が
東あるは住宅醸造専用の前に類です
それは説明させてもらうと普通のは
エネルギーのビジネスモールを考えると
は緩いはブドウを用意する自分で栽培する
か契約のから買ってワインにして直接に
炎龍ざー
酒屋さん
飲食店荒神客に売る
でも受託上その場合には農家さんが自分の
ブドウをは犬に持ってきて一緒にワイン
作らせてもらってそれでは緩いが安く農家
さんに売り戻して
で農家さんが自分の週販連気を使って炎龍
座に自分のは意図して売ります
そうすれば農家さんの経済状況が良くなる
1本のワインの売り上げの会
利益が1キロの部のより高いですから
でこれは支部酪農家さんたちと一緒にある
と農家さんが
自然にその
なんていうワインづくりーの
技術とか
えっと学ぶことになるしあとはそのワイン
の反応もできちゃうから最終的には農家
さんが
独立して自分のはに立ち上げることが目的
とあるの最大の目標がはエネルギーの件数
畑の件数できるだけ増やすことそうすれば
北海道のワイン原産地としてはより早く
形成される
ワイン原産地て
ちょっとインパクトのある動き
ワインはいろんな意味で面白いの産物だ
けどといろんな人を呼ぶ農産物
ローマンそのワインのローマン感じる若者
もよ星
食いしん坊もよ星
8お酒好きの人も呼ぶ
はにができたらその継ぎ目はワイン
ツーリズムが始まるでワインツーリズム
始まるといろんな人が終わり温いよって
くるそうすると悪いの周辺に
レストの宿
そして農産物の直売店が増える
それができたらえええっとそのは犬の周り
にその原産地にはちょっと丈夫な
えっと経済的な状況が出ちゃってそうする
と
その農業にちょっと復活してそれで我々
やっていることの意味で頑張れば
多分その日本の田舎はスギの世代のために
は守ることはできるかもしれないそう信じ
て今で私たちはこうやってます
それで今の話で3つの鍵ぬよく
栃木北海道
かなりバラバラの話ですけど
すべては一つの共通点あるたん皆さんは
わかりになってると思いますけどすべては
一つの小さいの質問から
貼ってる始まっている
その質問は
周りの人々のためには何かができるかと
いう質問
私の質と母はそういうような人たちでした
から子供ゴールから人間って
1尾
大互いに
あの助け合うことは基本だと教えられたん
で自分は実はそのワインは仕事として決定
したときにはこのような活動は
多分仕方がなく
その自分の所仕事ではなくそれは職場以外
のところでやれないといけないと思ったん
だけど知らないうちに思わずに
自分のワインの仕事でもできるようになり
ました
それで皆さん
和英自分の仕事人生多分今日の皆さんは
いろんな活動もしていると思いますが a
自分の人生自分の仕事にもその角なって
隠れてる不思議な力のものがあるならそれ
は見つけて一緒に頑張って明るい
未来に向かおうと思ってる
今日の話を聞いていただいてありがとう
ございます